proche justement monsieur de faire vous
êtes au centre du débat puisque vous
êtes ministre de l'intérieur aussi
ministre de la décentralisation une
décentralisation dont vous êtes
l'architecte et le champion et qui
risque fort de tourner maintenant au
bénéfice de vos adversaires mais d'abord
ce retour à la proportionnelle c'est
acquis c'est lors le programme qui était
présenté par le président de la
république quand il était candidat
la proportionnelle c'est un principe
quand il est facile de définir le rôle
qui consiste à ce que chacun soit aussi
bien représenté que possible tandis que
d'un scrutin majoritaire au second tour
on élimine beaucoup de voix qui ne
compte plus du tout qui ne sont plus
représentés enfin ça vous avez mal
réussi aux légistes n'ont ce que nous
avions le courant pour nous et pour
l'avenir
nous allons étudier tous les problèmes
car la proportionnelle c'est un principe
et puis il ya beaucoup de modalités et
nous verrons quelles sont celles qui le
souhaitent je ne risque pas d'aller vers
un mélange proportionnelle est
majoritaire je n'ai pas exclu
j'ai pas encore commencé le ton dès la
fin de ces élections pour le faire enfin
quoi commencer à étudier attentivement
le problème je vais le faire et reposant
au parlement un projet de loi qui comme
toute loi électorale prendra lieu sans
doute pas mal de discussions et que je
pense sera votée
vous avez déclaré hier soir qu'il
n'était pas question de faire marche
arrière en ce qui concerne la
décentralisation reste quand même à
fixer exactement la compétence des
nouveaux patrons de département que vont
être dante les présidents de conseils
généraux là vous n'allez pas quand même
laisser à vos adversaires autant d'armes
ou de munitions politiques
si si si c'est la vérité quand débat ait
lieu l'assemblée nationale j'ai été
accusé de vouloir politiser les conseils
généraux et quand on disait politisé on
sous-entend des goodies et clairement
qu'il était question une sorte de
mainmise du parti socialiste sur les
conseillers généraux sur les
départements en vérité j'avais répondu
c'était l'évidence est là la réalité le
confirme j'étais les électeurs qui
choisiraient par les électeurs ont
choisi de donner la majorité des
départements français à l'opposition ce
qui était parfaitement leur droit
c'est une hypothèse qui vont être
envisagées à
et aujourd'hui je tiens à le dire je ne
changerai pas le texte qui a été voté
bien sûr n'est pas question ni des
projets qui ont déversé des transferts
de compétences parce que l'opposition a
obtenu le plus grand nombre va obtenir
le plus grand nombre de présidents de
conseils généraux dans les départements
mais alors ce changement dont on dit
qu'il doit se poursuivre comment va-t-il
se réaliser dans les 58 départements où
l'opposition à la majorité qui demandent
à ma place on savait déjà pu mesurer à
quel point les présidents de conseils
généraux qui savait qu'il serait réélu
avait hâte de s'emparer du pouvoir et
même parfois d'aller un peu plus loin
mercredi prochain les préfets vont
transmettre aux présidents de conseils
généraux le pouvoir de gestion qu'on
appelle l'exécutif du département puis
dont la session du mois d'avril près
parlement s'amener à se prononcer sur le
transfert de compétences supplémentaires
de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales alors qu'il est on connaît
les compétences du département sont
notamment le problème des dettes
sociales les problèmes de gestion du
bâtiment du développement et notamment
de la voirie et les problèmes d' aide
aux communes
il s'ajoutera à cela un certain nombre
de choses quand le texte sera voté le
par le parlement et ensuite je
demanderai au parlement pendant la
session de printemps de voter des textes
sur la corse puisque en corse les
élections d'octobre à dieu comme mois de
juillet je ne changerai donc rien à mes
projets c'est ça la loi des démocraties
n'ont pas gagné
les hôtes ont gagné ils bénéficieront
avant nous et plus que nous dans plus
département que nous te loi
décentralisation je le regrette mais
tant mieux pour eux et on ne risque pas
de vous accuser de jouer ainsi à
l'apprenti sorcier en fabriquant cette
espèce de absolument pas car le préfet
qui s'appellera le commissaire du
gouvernement qui est aaa préfet le
préfet va disposer à l'avenir de
beaucoup plus de pouvoir que dans le
passé en effet le préfet avait une
double fonction il était le représentant
de l'état mais dans ce domaine
sa compétence était limité et le
représentant du département vis-à-vis de
l'état parce qu'il concerne son rôle de
représentant de l'état
il va désormais être le véritable
responsable de tous les services
ministériels installés dans des parcs
voilà ce que vous ne reprenez pas d'une
mince que vous donner un ordre
j'ai toujours dit et dans toutes les
discussions qu'il fallait que ceux-ci
jeu est équilibré
la décentralisation est une très large
déconcentration
car il faut que l'état reste un état
unitaire
c'est ce que le gouvernement a toujours
dit et le préfet en devenant le
représentant de l'ensemble du
gouvernement de chacun des ministres un
étang je m'excuse du mot vous aidera
peut-être le patron de la direction
départementale de l'équipement
d'agriculture d'agen cfa2 toutes les
directions ministérielles qui était un
département qui autrefois envoyer les
dossiers à paris pour qu'il soit traité
de dijon sera prise qu'après fait
étudiera les dossiers et prendre la
décision sur place il sera un homme fort
puisqu'il représentera l'ensemble des
services ministériels
monsieur de fer dans les commentaires de
vos amis politiques
une chose m'a frappé et moi et beaucoup
d'autres confrères à les entendre en
somme ces résultats des cantonales
décevant pour vous sept ans en gros la
faute aux journalistes
non alors jusqu'à quand et jusqu'où est
ce que les journalistes vont donc servir
ainsi de bouc émissaire chère
mademoiselle
il a été aidé avait souvent dans le
passé qu'il en soit assez
la défaite est mauvaise conseillère ceci
dit il est évident que nous avons sont
obligés de remarquer que la presse
écrite d'un sac dans sa très grande
majorité dans sa quasi-unanimité à part
quelques très rares journaux est une
presse de droite et que la télévision ne
nous a pas profité
alors qu'elle profitait à n'ont pas dit
s'ils devraient ou non je pense qu'un
objet gears 2 at il de vous écrit qu'il
convient pour éclairer façon complète
sans respecter mais elle nous donne une
opinion sonel comme mon père est né au
courant qu'elle soit bon
on ne l'est pas avec quelques jeux qui
peut-être l'élection 4ème mois ce
courant il reste de toute une seule
chose j'espère y contribuer une épine
capable d intervenir encore de faire sur
lesquels aimerions voir votre ex l'a vu
ces petits airs décès sont battus au
pays ce thème à faire du lait n'ont pas
terre dans son exploitation coliques
dans son aspect qui vous admirent la
femme derrière laquelle la ruse
l'instant certains livres et quelques
regrets dans le foisonnement de folie
pour la première attaque surtout les
nourrissons n'a pas actuellement
sk maman fait adrien or sur ce site pour
le mode de souk ahras polie elle suite
pensé dans le même rapport citant et les
russes l'avaient tenté main décollée
suggère de dire la justice
vous avez mois et demi serait là
judiciaire a pas de s'installer en fait
les ondes et les sea dogs quai ou ne
juge
j'ai donc pas fini mais les premières
nations et et sûreté urbaine mans à
12h10 la demande en seconde instance
nathalie l'ordre elles deviennent dans
l'état du maine j'ai personnellement
pardon pour deep et semaine d'ouverture
les nymphomanes qu'est la paix de l
expansion des communautés locales en
vous écoutant mais de répondre à une
demande des complices à faire l'inversé
de cesse à des scènes cocasses
vous allez main aux funérailles sont
rares naru taru l'ordination et
commentés française marais pape a
démenti aujourd'hui participer dans
l'attentât pourtant philippe bidart la
tenue du moment et rechercher maintenant
fascina c'est peut-être un piste ce
mouvement là peut-être à hauteur de ce
qu'ils représentent les condensés
présent à publi du gouvernement l'avait
déjà l'attention c'est le monde ait
jamais madame le consul sépare les
horizons du terrorisme d'extrême gauche
ou de droite les api cran et démocratie
directe violence qui m'ont police à la
place chaque aussi frémir le voir nous
posions venir en nombre a pu se dérouler
concret pays et nos actions est pas
content je demande que soient recherchés
les auteurs nîmes pour livrer la justice
ils ont sévèrement tout aussi vous
oublier mais quand il ya des
manifestations et là il a poignardé aux
trombes cecos il faut s'en prendre
directement à durham en supériorité
robin c'est ce que j'aime à merci 7